could we see the spice girls perform
again on dancing with the stars
i really hope so i think that could
really should we manifest that that is
going to happen yes so we are talking
right now we want to get out there we
want to do shows again we told the uk in
2019 then of course the world's gone
crazy so when everything's safe again we
want to get back out there so america's
kind of top of our list
are we gonna see you incorporate a
little spice girls dance routine into
your performances well you know it's a
big year for the spice girls because
it's 25 years since wannabe and the
first album what wow how did that time
go right i was like 10 when it happened
um so yeah so it's so wonderful and i i
really want to embrace that in the show
so it would be lovely and you know i'm
doing keeping my fingers crossed that we
get a bit of spice action and of course
i was here when melanie was in the show
melanie b in 2007. so have you talked to
mel b and what advice did she give you
she said just enjoy it lap it up and i
think you know all the girls i told it
all of them and they're all super
excited for me and they're kind of like
you've got to win i'm like
that's a bit of pressure and so i was
like i'll do my best um you know because
i'm the sporty one they all think yeah
she's gonna get gold but you know
there's there's more sporty people in
the show than me like well super support
who really have won girls there is a
zombie you know but you know i want to
give my best shot and it's such an
incredible thing to meet everybody the
whole cast this season is so lovely
and um i'm just looking forward to you
know spending time with everyone so what
songs of the spice girls catalog or your
own catalogue would you like to be able
to perform on dancing with the stars i
think all of the spice girl science
would be great you know because we have
beautiful ballads you know you could do
something really lyrical and beautiful
like to become one
[Music]
but then we've got the fun stuff spice
up your life
[Music]
wannabe
so there's quite a lot to pick from
maybe we should do a poll see what
people want me to do we want all of them
that that is the problem you're right um
will we hear you kind of talk about the
spice girls years on the show there's
many episodes where people look back on
their lives and you know talk about
certain memories of theirs what will you
get into emotionally as you go on this
journey yeah you know of course the
spice girls is such a huge part of my
life um i will always be a spice girl we
all feel like that you know and we're so
proud and so proud of the legacy that
we've left behind so
yeah spy skills are going to be a big
part of that and probably a lot about
where i'm from you know i'm from the
north of england and
i'm not far from liverpool of course
people know the beatles but um i love to
talk about that and how different life
is growing up i suppose in the uk you
know there are so many similarities but
so many differences so i think it'd be
nice for people to maybe get to know me
in a way they haven't before well you're
used to it i mean you've been performing
for years you know the drill with
dancing with being on the road and all
that how prepared do you feel though for
dancing with the stars oh my goodness i
i feel very unprepared
in fact it's like it's crazy i had my
first
um rehearsal yesterday
and it was wild because i have danced
you know with the spice girls we do our
little downstream teams i danced as a
kid i did ballet and it's like can you
just forget everything you've ever
learned it's so so different yeah and
all the styles have such different
techniques so i like a challenge
and it's a good job
who did you guys used to say was the
best dancer like was there one of you
who picked up the choreography fast
oh mel b definitely really she's always
yeah yeah super quick super quick but um
yeah i think i'm up there you're up
there
do you want to give mel b a run for your
money are you like i got to uphold the
spice girl's name right now um i yeah i
i have to i mean of course i want to do
great i want to do great for the girls
i'm representing you know so i'm just
going to do my best okay and how do you
feel about your partner i'm so happy
really i totally got who i wanted
[Music]
you